[Music]
so if you'll take a second look at the
plan you will see what I see and this
money not our money oh mama I'm in fear
for my life from the long baby where you
going oh this gold business
oatmeal here's ago but it's amazing how
little gold does can just change
everything damn it Kenny
and I'm so far from my
Mike mccoshen are we're talking about a
dream right here Indonesia
that's where we'll find the gold
[Applause]
we found nothing and the workers are
leaving wait wait wait okay look we got
a goal for better or worse the ride had
begun and what I never doubted you for a
second
this is Ryan Wolfe in New York they were
coming at me from all sides we believe
you're sitting on the largest gold find
of the decade we're talking over 30
billion dollars
washoe mining turned into a rocket ship
Wells cut a deal I'm kind of deal with
him this isn't a deal no bows no deal
open it a very powerful people of are
you angry
I'm really sorry sticking over the mind
these pings
are using you make it stick away maybe
it's my I family and the only question
I'm left with is how did 17 billion
dollars disappear overnight don't have
very long the letter to death nice to
meet you they're charmed I'm sure
know people write letters to the
universe all the time most don't get a
purse